From The Garden of Eden to the top corner
of your English teacher’s desk, apples have
played an equal role in history’s most remarkable
days and also its most mundane.
The sounds of teeth snapping through the skin,
sinking into flesh, and spitting out seeds
echo through space forever and onward.
And for most of our earthly hours consumed
by appetite, it has been documented to be
a lopsided relationship between these two
things, man and apple.
Man getting the sweet taste and abundant nutrients,
apples getting nothing but pain and stomach
acids.
But this story is found not in our history.
Buried in the lawful patterns of predator
and prey, we stumble upon an irregularity,
an inversion, an instance of apples biting
back.
SCP-4608, also known as APPLESEED, was a 60-acre
apple orchard containing over 22,000 trees,
located just on the outskirts of Milan, Indiana
– a town so small it strains your eyes as
you squint to find it with a microscope hovering
just over a map.
And to see what was actually happening within
the curious fringes of society took even greater
exploration, not just of the eyes but also
of the mind.
Because what would eventually be seen would
not so easily be comprehended.
Physical senses are just the surface, and
we need to go deeper.
Our story begins with a logging company looking
to take ownership of the most fertile land
they could find in the Great Lake Region,
ideally land that overproduces conifer growth
so that the return on their investment would
be plentiful and perpetual.
These lumberjacked men knew what they wanted.
Beneath their red flannel shirts and muddy
boots was a deep intelligence and understanding
of nature.
Their process of assessing the land’s value
was meticulously calculated.
They knew the soil, both by the experience
of their callused hands and the literature
of their study.
They tracked various bird species’ migration
patterns in the area to assess what kind of
seeds they’d be carrying and contributing
to soil by way of their stool.
They understood the local laws relating to
clear cutting and conservation and how both
would affect their profit margins.
This is all to say, it wasn’t just a speculative
purchase.
This was planned, thought through, and dwelled
on.
And yet, even then, with scrupulous eyes and
a careful crew, they missed the warning signs.
SCP-4608 checked all their boxes…and then
some.
What could go wrong?
And so they acquired the land, unwittingly
purchasing the peril that came with it.
On the first day of owning the property, one
crew member noticed the branches did not sway
in the same direction as the wind blew.
He noticed the leaves didn’t float down
in agreement with their feathery weight, but
rather crashed to the soil like two-dimensional
anvils and grand pianos.
The roots were not ones you simply trip over,
instead, it seemed as if they stuck their
leg out to trip you.
When birds perched themselves up high and
sang their songs, their cadence carried all
the eeriness of an SOS.
With all of this said, he was happy to have
acquired the land, and having already picked
up and moved his family from the West Coast
to now live and work out in Milan, Indiana,
he decided it best to look past his concerns.
After all, it was the first day on the new
site, and excitement was in the air…but
with it also an amorphous, anxious energy.
During the first logging expedition within
SCP-4608, this same member of the crew hiked
the grounds to better familiarize himself
with the environment he’d be working on,
hopeful that if he managed the land properly
and extracted the lumber as efficiently as
his late father did, he would be able to help
build the business and give his children the
life he always promised them.
He brought with him his notepad and took detailed
records of his surroundings.
He figured to achieve his goals and sustain
long-term yields, he’d have to cooperate
with his environment.
But he never questioned if his environment
wanted to cooperate with him.
Would this question have changed the course
of action?
Or is brooding on the preference of plants
an empty gesture, best left for hippies at
Woodstock?
Either way, the orchard let it be known how
it felt about a collaboration when hours later
the man was found dead.
It was first believed by his coworkers to
be a result of a safety equipment malfunction.
Maybe it was a simple matter of thinking the
skidder was in park when really it was in
neutral.
Maybe the Knuckle-boom Loader went on the
fritz how it does when the humidity ramps
up.
Maybe machinery really was to blame, in which
case you call it a fluke and ask no more.
After all, there’s only so many questions
you can ask a robot.
But initial belief is a fickle thing… and
it wasn’t long until first impressions were
called into question by the courts of critical
thinking.
The questions of the crew, however, only rang
briefly.
Because shortly after the first death fell
a sequence of others.
In a matter of days, all of the remaining
crew members were declared dead or missing,
a word reserved for search parties still clinging
to hope, a hot potato they would have been
wise to abandon.
For while it was hope that brought these search
parties together, it was hope that sent them
off… never to be seen again.
The Foundation was then alerted to the occurrences
surrounding SCP-4608 by police reports accompanied
by a photograph…a photograph of an SCP-4608-1,
an organism consisting of unidentified plant-like
muscular structures and a periderm resembling
those found on common hardwoods.
From the photograph alone, it was clear that
this 3-meter-tall organism was capable of
committing the violence recently endured.
Forceful in its demeanor, aggressive in its
presence, and territorial in its perception,
the photograph of SCP-4608-1 led to an even
bigger question… is this plant-like creature
grown by nature…or sown by man?
After extensive research by The Foundation,
records were retrieved that indicate the entirety
of the sixty-acre land was sown into life
by John Chapman in 1826.
Chapman was the type of man you could mistake
for a scarecrow, both for reasons of preferred
garb and body language.
He was treated as such too.
His personal space was respected…maybe too
much.
He spent his life alone, only accompanied
and comforted by the things he planted.
He maintained these acres all by himself until
his eventual death in 1845, and it’s then
that it’s believed SCP-4608 became unstable,
reassigning its objective from comfort to
chaos.
When the newspaper came out the next Sunday,
John Chapman's obituary painted him as a priest
of the Allen county church.
But was this just the art of illusion?
For as far as we know, no records of a chapel
or congregation exist… a quiet choir indeed.
Come to think of it, it seems that everything
within this sixty-acre orchard was destined
to be silenced one way or another, by violent
force or even by conscious decision making.
See, while the SCP has a long track record
of subduing anomalies by methods of capture
and containment, not all things are suited
for locks and chains.
SCP 4608 is better covered with a story than
a tarp.
A fruitless field that once produced at an
unmanageable pace is now rendered incapable
of supporting growth.
Most will think it’s due to a toxic spill.
In truth, the spill wasn’t that of chemicals
on soil… but rather corpses on crops.
A week after receiving the photograph of 4608-1,
Site-81 sent a three-man investigation team
to Milan.
Their adventure was equally abrupt: a story
with no reportable beginning or middle but
simply a predictable end.
After four days of no communication, the Foundation
presumed the three agents no different than
their steak dinner, dead meat.
And only then, after The Foundation’s failure
to solve the case, was it understood that
what we were to be looking for wasn’t people
at all…but rather answers to more nebulous
questions.
What’s really happening here?
And why is this happening?
Following the loss of communication with the
investigation team, Site-81 dispatched a high-risk
response team, Mobile Strike Force Bravo-7,
aka Hometown Heroes.
These men had all the makings of heroes, and
they were determined to prove themselves worthy
of that title.
While Alpha squad moved north toward the incident
site, BETA squad headed east and GAMMA squad
hurried west – the crews covering all directions
of the compass but south, a coincidentally
symbolic gesture as if to say we will not
be taken down!
The mission was simple in theory.
Find out what happened to the previous team
and why.
But, alas, missions never are as easy as their
objective statement reads.
In practice, some might even call them…impossible.
As ALPHA headed near the incident site, they
noticed the shadows on the ground beneath
them did not resemble the shape of the leaves
in the canopy above.
They heard small drops of liquid tap tap tap
on their helmets.
Yet, it wasn’t raining… was it?
ALPHA-1 ran his finger across the top of his
helmet and then examined the residue left
on his skin.
It was raining…just not water.
“Oh, god!”
Upon looking up, he witnessed the reasons
for both irregularities.
Bodies hung from branches by their intestines,
casting shadow puppets with their lifeless
limbs.
Blood dripped down like a leaky faucet.
“What did this?”
But before he could even ponder the answer,
he heard a loud shriek from his radio, so
loud that the radio itself vibrated, shaking
its way loose from his hand and falling to
the dirt.
He bent down and picked it up and this time
gripped tighter, as if to tell whoever is
responsible for that noise that they will
not get away that easily.
He and his crew followed the sound like a
game of Marco Polo, blind to what may be ahead.
They extended their guns and pointed them
into the distant tree line, like zombie arms
reaching outward in the pool toward the resonates
of “Polo”, a small comfort in a giant
game of distress.
As they pressed forward, ALPHA Squad proceeded
past all signs that pointed them back, stepping
over dead bodies like puddles on a rainy day.
Soon they found themselves crouching down
next to human remains, attending brief and
hurried funerals for all their closest comrades,
torn between staying to pay respect and marching
along to earn it.
The chest cavities of the fallen had been
ripped open and filled with apples.
A grim foresight into what they were up against.
But nothing they could ever imagine would
prepare them for what they were about to see.
And they wouldn’t have to wait long.
Another loud shriek from ALPHA–1’s radio!
It shot free from his grip and again landed
in the dirt.
The squad tried to ignore the metaphorical
implications of this recurrence, quickly picking
up the radio and shrugging it off as if the
five-second rule applied equally to communication
systems as candy bars.
They pressed forward, maybe out of bravery,
maybe out of shame of going back.
And while moving through trees, they began
to notice something alarming etched on their
bark.
What was it?
There were unnaturally deep grooves on the
base of almost every one of the trees.
But what exactly were they from?
Scratches from an animal or beast?
Infection?
Decay?
Their eyes drew closer.
But proximity brought them no clarity.
These sigils and symbols could be dated back
to occult Norse religion, but in that moment
they were incomprehensible to the men, yet
the message, even if misinterpreted, was very
clear: beware!
Another shrieking cry over the radio.
“The bullets…the bullets aren’t…
they aren’t working.
They can’t.
They can’t penetrate the bark!”
The grass is no greener over on the eastside
of the orchard, where BETA SQUAD gets lunged
at by an 4608-1.
Their defenses are futile, but they fight,
nonetheless, sending rounds to the attacker’s
chest - leading to…
Nothing.
If SCP – 4608 had a health meter, it wouldn’t
have budged in the slightest.
Understanding the negligible impact of their
efforts and assessing their injuries, BETA
SQUAD scurries to retreat to an abandoned
chapel, taking a brief refuge from war only
later to be named.
Quickly, they barricade the door.
In the chapel, Beta-9 tends to BETA-6’s
wounds, who is in the worst shape of them
all: cut, bloody, and beaten.
As he lays there grimacing, he shines his
flashlight up and down the chapel’s walls
until he finds a reason to stop and hold it
steady.
Illuminated is an assortment of human skulls.
And if this wasn’t traumatic enough, he
then spotted apple seeds embedded in BETA-6’s
wounds - Apple seeds that were starting to
sprout.
Beta-9 gave it to him straight.
“This is going to hurt.”
He drew his knife from his belt and lowered
it into his comrades' wounds.
Beta-9 dug into flesh and bone, picking the
seeds out, one by one.
Beta-6’s scream shook the chapel’s stained-glass
windows.
As BETA-1 stood guard, he saw a blur rip past
him, as if life had suddenly been turned up
to three times speed.
He spun around in a circle to try to keep
his eyes on it.
But as his vision refocused, he saw BETA-9
was now dead.
He then shifted his gaze to BETA-6, who was
looking less and less human by the second.
Branches began sprouting out of his body like
an all-consuming magic beanstalk.
Out of his chest.
Out of his eyes.
Out of his mouth.
And when there were no more orifices to exit,
his body exploded, making way for the new
form that had overtaken him.
The barrage of branches broke through the
windows, and the squads fell like dominos.
Dominos not just tapped over gently but kicked
by a toddler on full tilt.
Only two were lucky enough to be on the outskirts
of inertia.
Outside, GAMMA-1 was on his knees thanking
his dead comrade for the grenade he stole
from his back pocket.
“I could always count on you to have my
back.
Even in death.”
One hand holding a grenade and the other on
his radio, Gamma-1 called off Alpha-7: “Alpha-7.
Request for backup rescinded.
Go grab a burger.
I’ll take it from here.”
Gamma-1 slowly glanced up and locked eyes
with SCP-4608-2, a large apple tree with 13
human faces embedded into it, a perennial
plant with great powers, a gymnosperm that
has found a voice.
Blood poured from SCP – 4608 – 2’s empty
eye sockets.
Gamma-One smirks: “Get some eye drops, sicko.”
He crawled over to the beast.
The faces begin yelling at him in indescribable
tongues.
“Let me refer you to a speech therapist,”
he jokes as he pulls the pin of the grenade
and throws it toward the largest of the thirteen
mouths.
SCP – 4608-2 chokes on the grenade, forcing
it to inhale deeply… the strength of its
lungs pulling Gamma – 1 toward it and sucking
him in.
The grenade goes off.
SCP-4608-2 explodes.
The surrounding trees scream and combust.
The orchard goes up in flames, the bodies
of the fallen are given an appropriate cremation.
Gamma–1’s radio lay face up on the dirt.
A voice rattles it awake.
It’s Alpha–7.
“Gamma–1.
Gamma-1, you there?
Can you hear me?
Please.
Please, Gamma -1?”
On October 16, 1947 ALPHA-7 was recovered
by the Allen County Fire Department, unconscious
and suffering from exhaustion and smoke inhalation.
The Site-81 Concealment Team took control
of the situation and quarantined the area
using the cover story of a toxic chemical
hazard.
Following debriefing and a psychological evaluation,
ALPHA-7 was administered amnestics and switched
to low-risk recovery assignment.
The members of MTF Bravo-7 were posthumously
awarded the Foundation Star for their efforts
during the neutralization of SCP-4608.
And so, the one question that remains is…
how?
How did SCP -4608-1 become so dangerous, and
how did its danger slip by for so many years?
Is its volatility by nature, design, or consequence?
Could it be that the Foundation failed to
understand the complexity of this creation?
During Chapman’s lifetime, there were no
accidents or fatalities coming from SCP – 4608.
Yet, there is no reason to believe that SCP
– 4608 -1 wasn’t always capable of harm.
Maybe it always was capable of mass murders,
but simply had no reason to kill.
What if the logging company never stepped
foot on that land?
Never brought out their sharp blades and heavy
machinery?
What if this perilous orchard was in fact
docile, but provoked?
What if the proverbial tree only falls in
the woods when we force our philosophy on
it.
Though SCP -4608-2 spoke in unidentifiable
sounds, the noises were always recognized
and recorded as language.
It spoke with intent, even if misunderstood.
What it screamed is still unclear.
Were they pleas for help?
Or messages of hate?
And would one even be worse than the other?
John Chapman might argue, when facing heavy
machinery and trained artillery, would raising
your voice even be a moral decision at all?
Is fight or flight imbued not just in blood…
but also in bark?
Now go check out “SCP-1472 - Multiverse
Strip Club” and “SCP-4840 - The Flying
City of Audapaupadopolis” for more thoroughly
cursed anomalous locations!